good afternoon and thanks for coming I
am ernesto zedillo director of the Yale
Center for the
my colleagues and I at the center are
very pleased to host you this afternoon
for the presentation presentation and
discussion of Professor Ian Shapiro's
new book containment revealed in a
strategy against global terror I hope
you will agree that it is very exciting
to see that I scholar like Professor
Shapiro whose previous work has dealt
with great distinction with democracy
and justice has now decided to venture
into the muddy waters of global affairs
yes global affairs because when one
speaks about American foreign policy as
Professor Shapiro does in his book one
is for obvious reasons also speaking
about a policy that can affect the peace
security and prosperity of the entire
world professor Shapiro recognizes right
away that the United States confronts
less predictable more fluid and
open-ended challenges than the ones the
country faced in the cold world and we
are all aware what has been the approach
prefer by the United States government
to deal with these troublesome reality
of the early 21st century as you will
see during his presentation Ian's
Shapiro's message is very concrete there
is an alternative that is better than
the strategy follow until now by the
American government and the very
alternative in his view is not older
than the doctrine of containment
developed at the outset of the Cold War
of course adapted properly for the
post-911 world this suitable adaptation
according to Ian
calls for more not less of an active
reliance on international law and
institutions he submits to us that after
all successful containment always
depended on principle and predictable
American action on the world stage on
nurturing alliances with traditional
allies and on support for and judicious
use of international institutions given
professor Shapiro's central argument you
will understand immediately what that we
did not have to go far to find the most
pertinent commentators of his book we
are fortunate enough to have as members
of our faculty both the most
distinguished historian on the Cold War
professor John Lewis goddess as well as
one of the sharpest historians and
commentators on global and strategic
issues professor Paul Kennedy I thank
professors godís and Kennedy for
accepting the invitation to comment in
this session professor Shapiro's book
let me now ask professor Shapiro to take
the floor to provide a cig no seas of
his book I will then ask professors
goddess and Kennedy to give their
commentary following the remarks a
professor Shapiro ones we will return
the floor briefly to him so he can react
to their comments we will then welcome
your questions and after that we invite
you to a reception in honor of professor
Shapiro thank you
thank you all very much for coming and
and thank you to my colleagues for
agreeing to participate in this
discussion and however one comes out on
it I think everyone in the room will
agree this is one of the most important
subjects that we need to be debating at
this point in the history of our country
I should say at the outset that I backed
into writing this book in a rather
curious way in September of 2004 I was
going to Japan and I was asked if I'd
speak to the Yale Club of Japan to which
I agreed and I sent it three or four
topics of things I was then working on
and my host Jim Brook replied that his
membership wouldn't be interested in any
of them and that instead they wanted me
to speak about what the Kerry
administration's foreign policy was
going to be so I ended up giving a talk
on why there was not going to be a Kerry
administration and among the reasons
that I gave was that in politics it's
extremely difficult to beat something
with nothing and just as the Democrats
had been so badly damaged by their
failure to come up with alternatives to
the Republican domestic policies after
1994 so they were bereft of idea of
constructive ideas of their own in 2004
with respect to confronting the Bush
Doctrine as it had been developed and as
it hadn't played out after nine eleven I
think it another couple of pretoria
remarks power expands to fill a vacuum
and I think this is as true of ideas as
it is of anything else in in the this
particular book I'm concerned with the
the vacuum that was created by the
collapse of the criminal justice
response to terrorism the Bush Doctrine
and the war on terror as its come to be
called filled that gap fill that vacuum
while the Democrats stood by as
has mesmerized donkeys in the headlights
offering nothing in as an alternative
treating terrorism through the lens of
the criminal justice system made obvious
sense before 911 for one thing terrorist
groups or extra statist groups they are
not government's sometimes the members
of the group see themselves as
governments in waiting but they're not
really acknowledged as as public
entities in the way that governments are
secondly of course treating terrorists
as criminals denies them what they most
want namely political legitimacy the
very fact of treating them as criminals
by its terms refuses to acknowledge
their political agendas and then of
course there before nine eleven they had
been no successful mass attack if the
World Trade Center had fallen in 1993
perhaps the criminal justice approach to
terrorism would have gone with it then
but until the the collapses of buildings
started happening on 911 in New York we
just were not faced with in an attack of
on the dramatic scale and with the the
sorts of consequences of a public
assault on America and America's public
identity which was made it clear that
the criminal justice approach was going
to evaporate now let me say something
about what filled the vacuum the Bush
Doctrine as its come to be called was
laid out in the president's 2002 State
of the Union and then a series of
documents from the administration the
most to most important of which were the
national security doctrine of the US
published in 2002 and then an update of
that published in 2006 and I want to
flag six features of the Bush Doctrine
six defining features that I think mark
it off as the one of the most radical
see changes in
American history the first is that
nowhere is off limits the Bush Doctrine
asserts America's right to act anywhere
in the world the three countries
mentioned in the axis of evil speech in
2002 include North Vietnam which is 12
time zones from the east coast of the US
the only way you get North Korea I'm
sorry 12 time zones away from the east
coast and the only way you get further
away is by blasting off into space you
really have to go back to the Monroe
Doctrine to find America asserting any
comparable right in that case it was to
act anywhere in the New World in defense
of America's interests but in practice
the Monroe Doctrine was really only
enforced off the coast of North and
South America the Bush Doctrine if you
like is the Monroe Doctrine on crack
secondly the Bush administration
abandons the idea in in its
articulations of the Bush Doctrine that
traditional alliances should constrain
us action and replaces it instead with
the frankly opportunistic notion of
coalition's of the Willing the very idea
of coalition's of the Willing assumes
that any partner will do provided they
accept our goal for the pursuit of the
the agenda the issue currently being
pursued second thirdly the Bush Doctrine
embraces the idea of pre-emptive attack
abandoning their for the idea of war as
a strategy of last resort forth by its
very terms the war on terror
contemplates a condition of permanent
war no enemy can sign a peace treaty and
what politician is going to take the
risk of declaring that the war on terror
has been won perhaps a week before the
next plane flies into the next building
President Bush himself got badly burned
with his mission accomplished banner on
the aircraft carrier which turned out to
be flown just at the end of the phoney
war in Iraq
5th the Bush Doctrine explicitly rejects
the idea that anybody can be neutral in
the in the so-called war on terror if
you're not with us you're against us
President Bush had asserted the week
after 911 and again this is a position
that's been reiterated time and again in
statements of American policy implicitly
repudiating the hague convention on
neutrality and all of the benefits that
can flow from back-channel
communications and other possibilities
that come out of the presence of neutral
powers during international conflicts
finally and perhaps most surprisingly
the Bush Doctrine embraces the spread of
democracy around the world through
forcible regime change abandoning the
long-standing US and especially
Republican antipathy for imperialism for
an adventurer's nation-building and so
on all of which Bush had affirmed in his
2000 election campaign well the Bush
Doctrine as it's played out first in
Afghanistan and then Iraq is of course
drawn a great deal of critical fire and
as a lot of criticisms have been made of
it particularly by Democrats but one of
the arguments in my book and indeed the
overwhelming motivation for writing my
book is that these criticisms have
largely come down to charges about
incompetents failure to implement
changes properly and what has been
missing as being a contest of ideas what
has been missing as being the putting
putting out an alternative national
security strategy that can and should
command the attention of the American
people and more importantly of course
policymakers in Washington and as as
president zedillo said the the central
argument of the book is that the
doctrine of containment initially
developed at the outset of the Cold War
still provides the best tools for
preserving America as a democracy into
the future and it should be at the core
or of how we respond to terrorists and
other threats to our survival as a
democracy into the future now the Bush
administration initially was very
decisive in insisting that that the the
doctrine of containment was obsolete in
a world of transnational terror and weak
States and I have something to say about
both those things shortly more recently
particularly as they've been forced back
into a containment in dealing with North
Korea and increasingly in dealing with
Iran the this stance has softened
somewhat and we see increasing reliance
on formulations like the Bush Doctrine
the the doctrine of containment needs to
be supplemented needs supplementing by
the Bush Doctrine I I argue in the book
that this makes about as much sense as
saying that the traditional method of
putting out fires by pouring water on
them should be supplemented by pouring
gasoline on them and now it's obviously
true that a national security doctrine
developed in the context of a bipolar
world with set-piece conflicts is a
doctrine that will stand in some need of
modification given the sorts of threats
we face today but before I mention the
two principal modifications let me just
say something about points of continuity
first the Kenan developed the doctrine
of containment recognizing that national
security would have to be pursued in the
min the context of a world of scarce
resources this was the context of
demobilization and shrinking budgets
after World War two when President Bush
came into off with in 2001 we had budget
surpluses as far as the eye could see we
were at the end of the the merry 1990s
which had been America's decade in the
post-cold war glow alan greenspan was
publicly worrying that the country might
actually run out of debt if we didn't
cut taxes well we've solved that problem
we now have a so-called burn rate of 7
billion a month in Iraq and Afghanistan
we have a well in excess of one trillion
eventual war costs their budget deficits
as far as the eye could see so the the
fact that we have to think about
national security policy in a context of
scarce resources has returned and
Kennan's answer was that instead of
trying to dominate the global security
environment which is impossibly
expensive we should rather work towards
creating the world which nobody can
dominate and I explore that parallel at
some length in the book second
containment as formulated by Kenan and I
think part of its appeal depends on the
notion that the best way to spread
democracy in the world is not through
forcible regime change or even argument
Kenan insisted that arguing with the
Soviet leadership was a waste of time
since they saw our views as
rationalizations for a system that they
despise the obvious parallels there are
obvious parallels there with our
contemporary adversary's but in Kevin's
view the way you win hearts and minds is
by demonstrating the superiority of
democratic capitalism on the ground
hence his support for the marshall plan
to consolidate the democracies of
Western Europe as fast as possible again
in the book I argue there are major
parallels here in thinking about the
Islamic world indeed if you look at a
country like Iran and focus on the
population rather than the current
leadership there's a great deal of
pro-west and attitude and sentiment and
many things in common with the sorts of
things people discovered in countries
like Russia at the end of the Cold War
third cannon made a key distinction
between vital and peripheral interests
as a rational way for ordering threats
in the context of a world governed by
scarce resources never go to war over
peripheral interest and war should be a
strategy of last
zort with respect to vital interests
better to pursue peripheral interest by
other means democracy economic stick
diplomacy economic sticks and carrots
sanctions and the like war must be
contemplated when vital interests are
threatened but always as a resort as
it's terrible in a nuclear era and as
cannon himself put it shortly before his
death in observing why going to war in
Iraq was a bad idea with war you start
you know where you start but you don't
know where you're going to end final
point of continuity I think with great
lessons for our current circumstances is
that part of the way in which you create
a world in which which nobody can
dominate is to exploit and take
advantage of conflicts of interest in
competition among our adversaries he
welcomed Kenan was careful to insist
that the the opponent in the Cold War
was the Soviet Union not worldwide
communism and he actually welcomed
competition within the communist system
he welcomed the rise of Tito ISM as a
kind of internal challenge to Soviet
hegemony that would it make it more
difficult for them to achieve the kind
of expansion that they were looking for
so in in the way that the Bush
administration has prosecuted the war on
terror they've done the opposite they've
herded our adversaries together making a
self-fulfilling prophecy of Samuel
Huntington's dystopia of a clash of
civilizations the book revolves around
defending three claims that that
containment is a principled basis for
national security in a post-911 era that
it is a realistic basis and that it's an
attractive basis and I'll just spend a
few minutes on each of those before
turning over to my critics I think it's
principled for a reason that cannon
never articulated and indeed I think
kanan's approach was strategic all the
way down but
it's principled in the sense that it
involves a commitment to the idea of non
domination that if that the
interpretation of democracy that I
defend in the book is a commitment to
based on a commitment to the idea of non
domination and working for the creation
of a world which nobody can dominate is
therefore I think a principal gold
consistent with the fundamentals of
democracy the idea is to stop bullies
without becoming a bully yourself and in
that sense I think it's it's
pro-democratic and it's fundamentally
anti-imperial second it focuses on
proportionate responses to threats
making war a strategy of last resort
this makes it compatible with
traditional doctrines of just war and it
should be said it's it is containment
although proponents of containment all
the way back to the 1950s have always
been accused of appeasement containment
is not appeasement it turns on direct
confrontation of real threats refusal to
acknowledge their legitimate legitimacy
and explicit willingness to use force
when necessary few words about the
realism sure we'll have more discussion
of that later the obvious place to start
is the success of containment against
the Soviet Union during the Cold War
second point to make is the dangers in
the degree to which America has fared
poorly when we've abandoned containment
for this pursuit of regime change in the
past the the Viet involvement in Vietnam
bred in the end a virulent mix of
nationalism and anti-americanism and
we're now seeing a repeat of a similar
kind of virulent mix of Islamic
fundamentalism and national any American
nationalism in the Middle East a third
point on with respect to realism is that
the danger of with the danger involved
in going to war over a peripheral entry
is that your peripheral interest will be
your adversaries vital interest so they
have every interest in upping the ante
until you reach the point where domestic
support for your war is dissipating and
you'll have to leave as we did in
Vietnam and as we very likely to be
forced now to do in Iraq but forth on
the realism front containment worked in
Iraq between 1991 and 2003 we now know
and many people thought we knew at the
time that saddam hussein's iraq posed no
regional threat let alone a threat to
the united states and there are other
examples of its having worked against
rogue states terrorists takes the most
obvious one that i discuss in the book
is Libya which through the traditional
tools of containment was trained in
after 1990s stopped sponsoring terror
terrorism turned over the Lockerbie
bombers for trial paid compensation to
the British and French victims of Libyan
sponsored terrorism and eventually in as
quid pro quo for giving up sanctions
abandon its nuclear program and Libya
now there's no longer any kind of
serious threat to us as far as
sponsoring terrorism is concerned some
people said this was a response to the
Libyan compliance was a response to the
invasion of Iraq but the the chronology
of events defies that and the truth is
that Libya should have been the model
for Iraq just as it now should be the
model for Iran some a lot of attention
to the dating the problems presented by
transnational groups but I make the
argument in the book that the way to
deal with transnational groups is to
contain the sponsoring states and that
there's there's virtually none it's it's
it's not possible to make a plausible
case that any terrorist group can
present an ongoing national security
threat to the
nited states without some safe haven
somewhere and so the key thing is to do
is to go after the enabling states now
and that that the traditional doctrine
tools of containment lend themselves to
that enterprise of course the states may
be too weak we have a lot of discussion
in the media in the literature and so on
about weak states of course this is a
giant non sequitur as a defense of the
Bush Doctrine which offers no wisdom at
all on how to deal with weak states and
indeed however many weak states they
were in the world before we invaded Iraq
there's at least one more now and they
may well be three more if it breaks up
as many people expect I do argue in the
book that cannons doctrine needs to be
modified as as presidency do indicated
to involve much greater cooperation with
a regional players and alliances and to
make much more use of international
institutions Kenan didn't have much time
for international institutions he
thought they would be brushed aside in
any real conflict between the u.s. and
the USSR but in the world we face today
it's it's inconceivable that you can
manage the problems of weak states
without extensive reliance on those
things I I do as I said I go on to argue
finally that containment is an
attractive doctrine it doesn't put the
US on a permanent war footing with all
that entails for the erosion of civil
liberties and a military industrial
complex that Eisenhower couldn't have
imagined it promotes stability by making
the u.s. predictable in its
international conduct and it commands
support of the right allies who will
resonate with its root rootedness in
principle and its tactical realism thank
you
I now invite professor Kennedy mr.
Chairman I began with an apology I
didn't get a copy viens book until
midday on Monday which is my heaviest
teaching day and I had to give a new
lecture of my own on Tuesday so he and I
come to this with only 16 hours of
grappling with your work and I hope you
will take my comments as impromptu and
short-term responses not considered
thoughts i did have time this morning
though ladies and gentlemen to glance at
the business day section of New York
Times way on page see one there was the
article about the way academics argue
especially in Ivy League universities
and especially at Yale and david
leonhardt who came up to the debate on
the cost of global warming responses etc
when Stern was here and Bill note house
had to go to him said a typical way to
do this is before they attack somebody
else's work they need first to praise
they opponent a typical way to do it is
to describe in other professors a
distinguished scholar who has made an
important contribution to the research
literature when you hear that you can be
pretty sure things are about to get
nasty
once these politeness is out of a way
the two sides went added in the
dignified vicious way that academics do
well I'm going to try my best not to
imitate our economics colleagues of last
Thursday's debate here and I but I am it
is uncannily accurate description of how
academics debate and contend because
each of us feel i think is intellectuals
that we if if a colleague who presents a
thesis has has has pushed the envelope
than we in our truly Hegelian way have
to go for the antithesis and push it in
the other direction and we rely upon an
sto to bring us back to the synthesis at
the end of a session but i do want to
begin with with expressing admiration
for lots of things in Ian's shapiro's
book first of all it's short
it's a hundred and thirty-two pages many
years ago my wife said is it is there
ever going to be a time when you Paul
Kennedy can write a thin book and it's
coming i'm sure but but no yet but this
is a short book on a big an enormously
important topic as ernesto said at the
beginning secondly it's very clear in
the introduction and saying what it will
not do as well as what it will do and I
urge every student I teach her the
undergraduate and graduate-level to say
at the beginning of the essay what they
are not doing before they then say what
they're doing it's not discussing a
anorak exit strategy it's not discussing
the large debate about whether this Iraq
war and the legislation which has come
out surrounding the war has weakened
American democracy thirdly it seems to
me that this work is as critical of the
Democrats for lack of an alternative as
it is of the neoconservatives for the
fantastical mannequin view they have of
the world and of their flawed policies
in Iraq and elsewhere on reflection I
change that sentence I think it is even
more critical of the Democrats for not
having one idea in their empty cupboard
over the past nine years or so I given
what I've been recently writing and
talking about I welcome Ian's plug for a
return to buttressing the instruments
and institutions of in international
legitimacy I also agree with his
argument at containment it's almost
always a cheaper policy than war not
appeasement but as he says rightly and
him
makes this distinction containment is
some of you know cause you're in the
class i and professor gaddis and
professor Charlie Hill teacher a
year-long course on studies and grand
strategy and it's interesting that so
many of the grand strategists that we
think get things right are always pretty
cautious about pushing too far about
over extending we just finished a
wonderful session on Monday on comparing
with grand strategies of Philip the
second of Spain with the overextension
in all parts of a world and a grand
strategy of Queen Elizabeth the first of
England who took a large and long amount
of time before she committed herself to
the adjustment of the balance of power
and the support of a Dutch rebels and
the French in Western Europe in the late
16th century we will spend a bit of time
later on looking at those two late 19th
century grand strategists a Bismarck and
Lord Salisbury both of whom were
incredibly cautious about knocking over
apple cart because they were aware of
the unintended consequences of what you
did it was one of Klaus ovitzes nostrums
that you may have a plan and you may
have an intention before the war when
the war evolves you have very little
control of what goes on and so I really
applaud the notion that one should step
back and be careful about policies and
avoid policies which have this what is
manifest this massive counterproductive
impact upon world opinion towards the
United States and a massive
destabilizing impact across large parts
of a Muslim world because
conservatives were so certain now we
could just go in and clean up I ian has
described what he formulators with six
chief characteristics of the national
security strategy and the Bush Doctrine
and why they are novel and why they step
too far there I do recommend it they're
on pages 18 to 28 of this book about a
truly global nature about the
unrelenting nature as a particularly
fine area Ian if I may say so where you
discuss a way in which President Bush
and his team declare that they can no
longer recognize a neutral position you
either with us or against us so the
position of the Netherlands in the First
World War the position of Island and
Turkey and Portugal in the Second World
War the position of the United States
from nineteen fourteen to nineteen
seventeen and from nineteen thirty nine
to forty one is regarded under this
doctrine as being unsupportable you
cannot defend it you cannot defend a
country saying a plague on both your
houses I'm neither in favor of al-qaeda
but another favor of Cheney and Rumsfeld
and Wolfowitz and all of us people I am
play with in my dart board games in the
basement
let me then move on to some thoughts I
had about you but Ian ceases and about
the comparability because it is truly a
build an intellectual grab to take the
word containment which has such a
provenance in such a history and then to
say we can remoulded a new we can rework
it for our circumstance so why I kept
thinking why might the comparison or the
use of it not work well the containment
of the classic period that Professor
Garrett is such an expert on the
containment was if you like having it
the back of the curtain the fact that
both sides had the nuclear bomb it made
you cautious there was what Churchill
very early on recognized a mutual
balance of terror what's more the
containment was in a way sort of mutual
containment each side Washington and
Moscow had single governments and
unified and fairly sophisticated
decision-making processes this is well
covered in our colleague Paul dragons
first wonderful book the command and
control of nuclear weapons we first of
all an endless Soviets a few years later
realized you had to put an awful lot of
stops and checks in place to make sure
that things didn't go off accidentally
like in movies like failsafe or dr.
Strangelove we were close to it on a
number of occasions and we learned it
but we were contained and they were
contained there you can think of the
exceptions when the North Koreans poured
into the south and you can also think of
how close we got in the Cuban Missile
Crisis but on her we respected their
space and they respect
did our space if there were wars and
they were indeed many bloody wars in
Africa and Southeast Asia they were not
war central to the existence of the two
superpowers no to superpower alliances
there was a balance this of course is
why our good friend Monsieur Putin is
complaining so vigorously when he gets
to Munich to the fort idea gongs
conference and elsewhere about what
United States has been doing it has been
destabilizing that balance with the sort
of policies that Ian describes in his
book it's been pushing the envelope too
far here's a second thought about
whether we can have this containment
policy of the 55 years or 50 years of
the Cold War carried on to a long
grinding duel against global terrorism
it is is it it's a question which large
numbers of people from David Brooks
upwards or downwards wherever you place
David Brooks ask does the US people with
its traditional culture of wanting
decisive ends to conflicts or football
games or basketball games does it have
the patience to regard this as something
the containment policy not be pushing
165,000 troops into Iraq but the
containment policy diplomacy alliances
intelligence were police work going
through the international legal system
and the criminal courts does it have the
patience for that there's a large number
of people who say no we don't i i'm i
don't think i buy that if the British
people can take attacks by the IRA in
London and Birmingham and Belfast and
elsewhere for
40 or so years if the Italians can take
the Red Brigades if the Spanish can take
decades of attacks by the Basques I
don't see why we can't provided we
understand the nature of the engagement
I guess he and my big question on this
issue would not so much be can the
American people take a long sustained
not decisive containment policy but can
our good friends and nail conservatives
have the patience the short-fused guys
who are trying to discover just how many
missile warheads it would take to knock
out here and do they have the patience
but here's my final thought and probably
the biggest if you like criticism of the
argument in this in this very fine brief
book what ian is talking about is that
double containment seems to me now he
links for two things that he wants us to
contain but one of them is one of the
things he wants us to contain our
centralized rogue states and the other
thing he wants us to contain are
decentralized terrorist networks now
Ian's argument I think it has some power
is that if you take out the enabling
States or the enabling governments you
badly weakened the second of our foes
that the networks after all I guess
containment has worked against Libya it
looks like it might be working rather
well against that mysterious nutcase
state of North Korea there's a large
number of people a year as among them in
his book who argue that the prospects
for diplomacy vasavi Tehran are not
totally exhausted so I would buy the
notion the containment policy these are
V dubious States renegade state states
which are pushing towards nuclear power
development and we're not quite sure
whether it's going for the military
dimension of nuclear power or the
Pacific development of energy supplies I
think it works but I guess my final
question ian is containment assumes as
as cannon assumed that there was a kind
of rational actor on the other side
somebody who would say well the odds are
just too great to push it too far you
contain us but we are containing you and
we mutually agree that we can't push it
past certain limits and I think the
rogue states and the oddball states
still have central regimes and still
have roughly speaking rational actors
running them but I I'm just not
convinced that the fundamentalist non
sta terrorist groups and cells not
controlled in many cases locally
mobilized in many cases and more than
that carried on by a transcendentalist
belief I I asked this question when we
were trading Philip a second of Spain in
the grand strategy class on Monday we
look at Philip as being
too consumed by religion too consumed by
his passion to convert to turn the
Protestant movement back etcetera
etcetera and we say oh that's not a very
good grand strategy is it you've got to
be rational like Queen Elizabeth was but
what happens if Philip is right we're
all on this earth for a brief time now
we had carried upwards to the pearly
gates and st. Peter says yes or no and
Philip a second of Spain and the Muslim
fundamentalists and the grandmothers who
blow themselves up in a Tel Aviv market
go through those pearly gates whether
they're Christian or Muslim or Viking or
whatever how we doing do we really
understand the nature of those who think
that dying for their cause is a central
part of their world in their belief
system and if we buy the fact that they
may be unmoved by rational materialist
diplomatic signaling shows a force
aircraft carriers in the Persian Gulf
and everything else like that then I
wonder if they can be contained in the
way that I suggest the rogue states
probably can thanks very much
well naturally when I heard that my good
friend Ian Shapiro was writing a book on
containment and Kenneth this attracted
my interest my ears began to prick up
after all professor Shapiro is a
distinguished collar scholar who has
made a major contribution to the
research literature I'm happy to stand
here this afternoon and tell you that I
agree with everything professor Shapiro
says in his book about about the
deficiencies of the Democratic Party
with the rest of it I mostly disagree at
first George Kennan who is the
centerpiece of Professor Shapiro's book
as he has become in the last year or so
the kind of icon before the democratic
party mark dinner William Fath Kenan is
really being sanctified in this sense
now in a way that I think would have
pleased him greatly because he's found
so little sanctification or even respect
within the Democratic Party in the years
in which he was alive it's true he gave
these interviews shortly before his
death bashing the Bush administration he
would love to be used in the way that
ian is using him here but nonetheless if
you go back and look at his track record
as a guide to the Democratic Party it
seems to me he would have been the first
to say and I have heard him say they
don't listen to me perhaps there were
some reasons for that take for example
the following quotation and see who you
think said it quote every question we
placed before the United Nations means
one more question in which we have
forfeited the possibility of acting
boldly and independently in our own
interests John Bolton perhaps no George
Kennan 1948 ian is quite right to say
that Kennan's enthusiasm for the United
Nations was measured in fact I would say
that is a measured characterization of
canons attitude toward the United
Nations he famously in his book American
diplomacy portrayed democracy as like a
dinosaur with a brain the size of a pin
this was not particularly well
calculated to win him influence within
the Democratic Party and perhaps that
contributed to the failure of Democrats
to listen to him at least even sent and
said publicly during the nineteen
fifty-six campaign that while he respect
canon he disagreed with canon proof
profoundly on the proposition that
Eastern Europe was going to have to
remain under Soviet domination Dean
Acheson was even more cutting in 1957 in
Canon proposed soviet-american
disengagement from Europe and the
neutralization of Germany Kenan Atchison
said had never grasped the realities of
power relationships but rather had a
mystical attitude toward them Paul nitsa
following on this said Kenan is not an
Earthling so these compliments from in
Shapiro and this holding out of kenan as
a guide to the future course of the
Democratic Party certainly would have
gratified George but at the same time
does not reflect the actual realities it
seems to me of his influence in the past
within the Democratic Party but what if
containment the strategy that will of
course always be associated quite
properly with Kennan's name well it
seems to me the first point to make and
it's one that I made expending several
hundred pages in the process of doing so
and uncountable trees felled in forest
the first point to make is that
containment was not a single strategy
containment went through a lot of
modifications and permutations over the
years so many that Kenan himself by the
mid-1960s had emphatically denied
paternity of the doctrine of containment
in the first place he said famously in
his memoir that having given a rise to
the strategy of containment is like
having pushed accidentally a large
boulder over the side of the cliff
wincing and shuddering with every
glimpse of disaster below as this thing
rolled on and on out of control and that
was surely the attitude that he had
toward it containment was used to make
distinctions between vital and /
world interests yes but containment was
also used to defend making no
distinctions between vital and
peripheral interests as in NSA 68
containment was used to make the
argument for limited resources and
constraining American foreign policy
within those limits yes but containment
was also used to make the argument that
resources were infinite and that the
United States could afford to do
anything and that too was done in the
name of companion containment was used
by Kenan to criticize the American
performance in Vietnam but the
architects of our Vietnam strategy very
much thought that they were following
the strategy of containment when they
went into Vietnam my point is simply
this is an ambiguous complicated legacy
containment meant not one thing but a
lot of different things to a lot of
different people at a lot of different
times and so its usefulness in this
different situation it seems to me is
limited because one has to specify more
clearly it seems to me then ian has done
what form or what variety or what
manifestation of containment you're
talking about obviously containment was
as Professor Kennedy said a state based
strategy this is another problem that I
have with it i think it was constrained
by the fact that it emerged from an era
of state domination how useful it is in
dealing with non-state actors is I think
a serious question certainly how useful
it is in dealing with individuals who
cannot be detected before they act and
for whom death is no deterrent is an
extremely serious question this actually
was the starting point for the Bush
administration's critique of containment
in the aftermath of sep tember 11th the
idea that containment alone deterrence
alone on the cold war model we're not
adequate to deal with those kinds of
threats and I still believe that
statement by the bush administer
to be true professor Shapira is quite
right I think to point out that
terrorists do require the support of
estates in order to function but
nonetheless what happens when those
terrorists actually move how one
actually contains those states when
these activities are as invisible as
they were with al-qaeda and the Taliban
in a country let me remind you that was
itself almost as far away from American
shores as is North Korea how one
actually deals with those dangers it
seems to me in to what extent one can
deal with those dangers through the
traditional strategy of containment is a
serious question I think not answered in
professor Shapiro's but now Kenan
himself was careful to point out as Ian
mentions in the book that containment
would not work against certain
adversaries Kenan said it would never
have worked against Napoleon it would
never have worked against Hitler it
would not work against adversaries whose
calculation of risks was not the same as
our own and I think that's what
Professor Kennedy was alluding to when
he pointed out that we shared a lot of
common assumptions with our Cold War
adversaries I'm not completely sure that
we do in this regard so I fear that in
making his case for containment
professor Shapiro has assumed too easily
a shared rationality with our
adversaries this is ironic because it's
as if he has fallen under the spell of a
tendency he has himself elsewhere
criticized as a pathology rational
choice this leads me then to my third
point which is the adversary it's so I'm
still not quite clear from reading the
book just who or what the adversary is
mr. Shapiro tells us in the book that
suicide attacks are nothing new that
they have little to do with Islam and
yet I very well remember in the day that
you and I lunged at York side just a few
hours after a terrorist attack that did
seem intensely new had happened in fact
one that did have a good deal to do with
Islam I think we both agreed at the
timer I thought we did that the world
had changed dramatically as a result of
that day September 11th I still think it
has and that would be one of my
questions as to what extent you still
think it has in your own the way in
which you're portraying in this book I
think that what's missing in the book is
the extent to which the challenge we
face is only partly that of rogue states
but also the challenge to the state
system itself to the international state
system and to the liberties with which
we associated just a few more 911s
strategically placed it seems to me
could fundamentally disrupt our society
and the international stage system it
wouldn't take much this is where I
disagree with Professor Kennedy that
it's possible to tolerate continuing
terrorist attacks that maybe if you're
talking about the IRA or you're talking
about the Basque separatists over a
period of some years but none of those
attacks were anything like what this
country suffered on sep tember 11 so I'm
by no means confident that we or any
other society could tolerate a
succession of even a few more September
11th like the text that is the reality
it seems to me that we confront these
dates and I think it's a reality that is
not sufficiently acknowledged in Ian's
book in then concentrates on yet another
danger which is to be contained
professor Kennedy pointed out the danger
of terrorists professor kennedy also
pointed out the danger of rogue states
but he missed a third threat that
Professor Shapiro in his book thinks
badly needs to be contained and this is
of course the Bush administration it
seems to me that this
in an interesting way commits precisely
one of the errors of which it criticizes
the Bush administration and that is it
demonizes its enemies ian says this of
Bush and his advisors but it seems to me
that in does the same thing in this book
the Bush Doctrine he tells us is
unsustainable the Bush Doctrine is like
trying to put out fires with gasoline
the Bush Doctrine is on crack more harm
can be done still before the Bush
Doctrine finds its way into the trashcan
of history we are even told at one point
and Bush administration is following the
model of Hermann Goering in the book um
said to me at the beginning as we were
sitting next to each other this book is
not subtle he is correct in this regard
this is strong stuff so much so that it
echoes it seems to me certain New York
Times columnist sue and append writers
who themselves echo each other every
morning when we open the daily paper
over breakfast well what I sike what
exactly is the Bush Doctrine itself in
has given us about six different
definitions of it I found three separate
definitions of it just on page one of
ian's book but I think something is
missing here because it seems to me one
of the characteristics of a doctrine is
its quality as a projection of intention
into the future as opposed to a
statement of how one will handle or has
handled immediate situations the Monroe
Doctrine certainly was that and in that
sense I think there is a comparison to
be made the Truman Doctrine certainly
was that as well but as I look through
the bush administration statements and
try to find comparable statements
projecting into the future comparable to
the Monroe Doctrine and to the Truman
Doctrine I don't think it's a statement
that we are going to intervene wherever
week
used to do so in the rest of the world
actually no place where the Bush
administration has said that I see no
indication that the Bush administration
is practicing that what I did see in the
second inaugural was the statement that
it from President Bush that it must be
the policy of the United States to seek
the spread of democracy and the end of
tyranny throughout the world the
president was careful to say that this
was a long term doctor and it could not
be accomplished in his administration it
could not be accomplished even in this
generation but it was a long term
objective roughly analogous it seems to
me to determine doctrine and the cannon
strategy of containment that the Truman
Doctrine was based on that seems to me
to be the closest analogy from what the
Bush administration has actually said
now of course maybe Bush doesn't mean it
maybe he's insincere maybe it was just
Retter maybe it's totally impractical
maybe we shouldn't even attempt this but
instead should reverse this course of
spreading democracy and seeking to end
tyranny but let's be clear on what we
would be doing by reversing that course
we'd be reversing most of the course of
American history and what this country
has stood for in the world over the last
200 plus years all of these are
debatable points but I don't think they
are really ignora beloit sit seems to me
that they have to be addressed if in
fact we're going to have a serious
discussion of how the democratic party
can regain credibility and national
security affairs which is the main and
certainly the Holy admirable objective
of Professor Shapiro's book in his
conclusion he provides another list this
one of five national security
injunctions that should form the basis
of a democratic party grand strategy one
that is he says morally superior to the
bellicose unilateralism at the core of
the Bush administration's recently
reiterated national security strategy I
went back to the 2006 national security
strategy statement just to check this
really find very much bellicose
unilateralism in it I found a good deal
of rethinking and learning and
reassessment and caution after all this
document was actually about half drafted
by one of Professor Kennedy's and my
students and he's about as far from
being bellicose as it's possible to
imagine it's interesting that the NSS
documents are not actually quoted in the
Shapiro book they're referred to but
they aren't actually quoted and I think
the language of these documents is
important and at the same time neglected
I don't think you'd find much
disagreement with these basic
fundamental principles particularly ones
you lay out at the end of the book in
the final chapter at least in these
national security strategy documents so
in short I came away from reading this
book with a question that started
running through my mind it's one some of
the older people in this room will
remember having that made famous long
ago by one Democrat running against
another Democrat for president the
question was where's the beef I would
rephrase this as where's the strategy I
don't think the strategy for the
Democratic Party now can really be
containment because that was the
strategy meant for another time and
another adversary however successful it
may have been in the long run I don't
think this strategy can be bashing bush
in the spirit of non diversity so
favored by the New York Times because as
Professor Shapiro notes more than once
and he's noted it here today you can't
beat something with nothing you have to
have a positive alternative and of
course to paraphrase another famous
politician you're not going to have Bush
to kick around much longer the strategy
for the Democratic Party cannot be it
seems to me or cannot reside in
minimizing the dangers that face us
because the next terrorist attack would
completely discredit any strategy that
attempted to do this and that's got to
be factored in into anybody's
mystic grand strategy the democratic
brand strategy cannot neglect
relationships between ends and memes and
I think the Bush administration has
grievously neglected such relationships
so I'm not here to defend the grand
strategy in all respects of the Bush
administration these are major
deficiencies they are major
considerations but I think they need
more positive and explicit guidance than
ian has given us in this book it seems
to me fundamentally and finally that
this new grand strategy does have to
come and hear I agree from the
Democratic Party because that is how the
American two-party system works the
American two-party system works by each
party correcting the errors of the other
part but at the same time sticking to
certain fundamental common principles
that we all share and again that was
another thing that I found missing in
the Shapiro book was a clear discussion
of what fundamental principles Democrats
and Republicans do share can share
should share in thinking about grand
strategy so I had hoped to find all
these things in this book upon finishing
it I found to my regret that I was still
looking for the beef I'm still hungry my
only other concern as I conclude is to
wonder why it is that Professor Kennedy
has never actually let me into his
basement and I'm going to go down and
inspect his dart board
yeah you I'll respond briefly this I
know this is a topic one one thing about
this topic is it everybody has used
about it and I'm sure people will want
to ask questions and make comments I'll
just say a few a few brief things in
response to some of the some of the
criticisms raised by full Kennedy and
John gatos Paul Kennedy really took I'll
just I'll mention three of the things he
said the first is that he he questioned
the relevance of a doctrine of
containment that was was after all droom
dreamed up in the context of nucleus
states that could contain one another
and could propose great threats to one
another and wondered how relevant that
is to the world of the present and
future well it seems to me taking
professor Kennedy's argument on its face
is a very good reason for thinking we
should be adapting containment to the
present in the future because after all
we're facing a world of inevitable
nuclear proliferation and we are indeed
going to be dealing with more and more
countries that can threaten one another
in the ways that the Soviet Union and
the u.s. threatened one another during
the Cold War think about a country like
night made the point that well we will
they were all very predictable in their
actions but of course when China began
to develop nuclear weapons in the 1950s
nobody really knew much about the
predictability of the Chinese regime
nobody knew had any reason to think they
would be more susceptible to rational
thinking than we have reasons to think
about the Iranian regime today indeed
Iran one of the interesting facts about
Iran is Iran is a status quo power they
have no territorial designs on any
country in the region they've never
act any country in the region they've
always been extremely cautious in their
dealings with us and this there's no
particular reason in the world to assume
that they're any less subject to the
instruments of containment than then
China was let's say chicken the point
about double containment he takes my
argument with respect to Road States but
one is about terrorist networks
obviously the problems of terrorist
networks are legion but the argument I
make in the book is that what's needed
here the supplement containment are is
not the Bush Doctrine which offers no
help at all on this front but fairly
traditional tools of national security
such as improved financial counter
terrorism improved human intelligence
improved Homeland Security in the end
the list goes on but these are I think
these are largely uncontroversial since
they not at what is at issue between
defenders of the Bush Doctrine and
defenders of containment and then the
third point which is also a point raised
by John Gattis has to do with the
rationality of the adversaries how can
we contain people with the use of
incentives when they may not be rational
in the sense that that requires well
really I think there are two points
first of all I think that containment
just by its very terms does not
necessarily require that the person
being contained is rational we contain
wife batteries we contain psychotic
patients we contain people in all sorts
of circumstances where they pose threats
to us where we may well have given up on
the possibility of reasoning with them
and indeed one might think of those
sorts of analogies when thinking about
hamming saddam hussein in with no-fly
zones and so forth as a form of
containment so can i don't think i think
this would be an interesting discussion
to have but i think
one of the distinctions between
containment and deterrence is that I
think that deterrence assumes more in
the way of rational capacities on the
other side then containment actually
does as I said the goal of containment
is to stop the bully without becoming a
bully but sometimes the bully can only
be stopped it doesn't stop him wanting
to be a bully or bullying if he can but
then secondly and this is dis applies to
both containment and deterrence I argue
at some length in the book that if you
really want to think about the rational
capacities of it adversaries it's a
hugely important distinction to make is
between the people who actually blow
themselves up and the people who send
them and the real the real threat comes
from the people who send them because
the the number of self starting
self-organizing us suicide attackers in
the world is small and indeed they're
not necessarily Islamic fundamentalism
in the the most remarkable case in
American recent history would be the
Oklahoma City bombers so and I think
such be truly self-organizing
self-directing suicide attackers like
the Oklahoma City bombers will perhaps
some of the people involved in the in
the 77 London attacks these the
containment doesn't work with them but
neither does the Bush Doctrine those
kind of people have to be dealt with
through the criminal law despite what I
said about its lack of availability is
this response to worldwide terrorism but
in the main and you know one of the
burdens I try to take on in the book is
to work through the examples of the
major terrorist movements that where
people have said they're unstring and
show that the leadership's of these
groups are highly strategic from bin
Laden to the leadership of Hezbollah to
the leadership of the PLO to the
leadership of Hamas so much of the book
is devoted to showing how usually when
we think they're behaving irrationally
it's because we don't understand their
goals and with respect to Professor
goddesses point about my earlier work on
tional choice I think it's all of a
piece because really the argument there
was that if you look at where rational
choice that does well it tends to do
well with much better with politicians
than with voters for example just as in
economics it does much better with firms
than it does with consumers
self-consciously strategic actors tend
to behave just strategically and I make
that case in the book a couple more
points in response to Professor
goddesses remarks I I have no interest
in fighting over George cannons corpse
and I fully agree that some of his views
are not not only on containment but on
other issues such as race and many other
things I would not embrace his views I
have no interest in ionizing or
lionizing containment Kenan but I think
the central idea of containment is his
idea and that is the place where one
starts I also agree very much with
Professor goddesses comment developed at
great length in his book strategies of
containment from which I learned an
immense amount that there been many
strategies of containment and they're
not mutually compatible and indeed I
think one of the most useful
distinctions he makes is between what he
calls asymmetric and symmetric
containment in his book and but I also
agree with his analysis in that book
about why the symmetrix containment it
ends up being unsustainable partly
because of costs if I have the
terminology correct correct I think I do
and I so certainly there have been many
varieties of containment and I only
defend one variety and and indeed it's a
variety which involves some disagreement
with kennan about the reliance on
alliances regional alliances such as
NATO which I argue with Munez and others
we should really be having more of and
the reliance on international
institutions so it is one particular
variant of containment
and there have been others but I don't
think that even professor Gatos would go
so far as to say that the Bush Doctrine
is a variant of containment then finally
I think what are the what are the
underlying principles that Democrats and
Republicans should share in should
become the basis for a national security
strategy that what I defend is really a
two-pronged principle that the first is
the preservation of Americans in their
democracy into the future and then
second to the degree that it's
consistent and compatible with that the
promotion of democracy around the world
and I have some discussion in the book
which we haven't really talked about the
democracy at all much in this tooth in
this symposium but of the ways in which
it is and it is not possible to promote
democracy around the world consistent
with a strategy of containment thank you
we now open the floor for questions if
you have some questions I will ask you
to go walk to the microphone go ahead
my my question with regards to this
panel I'm in the medical field and it it
seems to me that the for the three
doctors here are looking at the symptoms
and perhaps we need the fourth doctor
that looks at the underlying etiology of
a disease I wonder if we had somebody
like Howard's in here or somebody like
professor edward syed or Martin Luther
King what they would say about these
issues and about the military-industrial
complex and how it relates to their
perpetual wars not about the tactics of
waging this worse I wonder if you could
address if it's possible to have a more
complete panel by looking at these
underlying it seems to me like the story
of the elephant and the blindman trying
to touch it and there is a bigger
elephant in the room that's not being
described properly science question I
think well I guess I maybe we should
collect sure you know I I think it's
quite plausible to say that the the
pressures behind the military industrial
complex have had something to do with
the Bush Doctrine particularly as its
it's played itself out in Iraq and
indeed you know I do have a considerable
amount of discussion of under the
heading of corruption of the huge
amounts of money that are being made
which will certainly dwarfed by many
orders of magnitude the the rather small
amounts of corruption that attend the
oil-for-food programme for instance
which was lambasted by defenders of the
Bush Doctrine in the in the run-up to
the Iraq war I would I what I do want to
say is that I think that it's a mistake
to think that I'm at
national security doctrine should do
everything I think that it may well be
the case that there are important
questions to address that it doesn't
address but but it's it seems to me that
even if one grants the proposition that
there is a military industrial complex
that is creating a lot of the pressure
to for the u.s. to engage militarily in
the world that still leaves us with the
question of what should the principles
be that guide our national security and
that's the question I'm addressing in
this button I just add to that the
military-industrial complex at the
moment is consuming something like if if
you mean the defense budget something
like four to five percent of GDP that's
about half what it was in the Vietnam
War it's far far less than what it was
historically at other points Korea World
War two so in economic terms it's much
less of a burden than it has been in the
past not much we get a quorum yeah thank
you I'd like to frame one of the
criticisms frame one of the criticisms
that's been levied at you so far in
possibly a different way I see actually
a little bit of an irony in proposing
containment as an alternative to
neoconservatism because I see
containment suffering from the same one
of the same structural issues that
neoconservatism faces and makes it
somewhat irrelevant in dealing with the
terrorist threat and that is the
concentration on state actors within the
system as the primary point of of action
and you know professor God has talked
about the impact of sep tember 11th
September 11th was suicide bombers and
as you pointed out suicide bombers are
are not sent by nations and so i wonder
if-if containment isn't a non-starter
for dealing with the issues that we're
facing today in the same way that
neoconservatism is announced
while suicide bombers are sent by
organizations which have havens in parts
of the world that are governed by States
so the argument in the book is that
apart from the usual tools of
intelligence human intelligence
financial counterterrorism and so on
that you can use chance nationally at
the end of the day you have to work with
the world of states now when these are
vey burien states in the sense of being
functioning states as you know as Iraq
was as Iran is as North Korea even is
though perhaps more marginally the
argument is that there's no there's no
alternative there's no feasible
alternative but for going but for going
after the enabling States and after all
it is still a world in which states have
armies and police forces and do aspire
to be vey burien they do aspire to have
monopolies of legitimate force within
their territories the harder case i
think is the failed states the weak
states and the argument i make in the
book about them is is twofold one is
that the Bush Doctrine makes the weak
state problem worse did in Iraq I argue
in the book we had enough time for it
here but I argue in the book they've
been doing so in Lebanon as well but and
and that the way you contain weak states
is by working with regional players
creating regional of alliances people
who you have to press into the service
of containment the potential spoilers
it's absolutely inconceivable the bacon
Commission is right almost everyone
else's looked at this is right it's
absolutely inconceivable that we're
going to be able to contain terrorism in
post occupation Iraq without cooperation
from Syria and Iran that is going to be
the root and the Syrians cooperated to
us with for three decades in Lebanon
Iran has many stability interests in
common with us in the region including
avoiding the breaking break up every
which might well precipitate Kurdish
separatism in their own country so we
need to work with regional players and
we need to work with international
organizations that are likely to have
the knowledge on the ground and the
capacity to know who the player key
players in weak states actually are but
at the end of the day we're still going
to be forced into trying to contain
terrorist groups by going off to the
places that give them safe haven okay
let me dig my ear okay the main
criticism I've heard against professor
Shapiro's argument is that containment
might not be a good argument because
it's not a state actor that we're
dealing with social movement I'm aware
of two social movement theories what is
the resource mobilization theory and the
other is the zygmont bloomer theory of
social movements which as far as I know
has never been published but which is a
very good theory and in terms of both of
those theories I think it's entirely
possible to have a containment approach
to any social movement of this type
sounds plausible to me thank you
professors for a very thought-provoking
discussion now i will keep thinking
about it as many of my colleagues
professor Shapiro how would you respond
to a critic a silly would say that it's
only in the world of academia that these
dichotomies between containment and
regime change exists only on paper the
containment strategy began after a
series of regime changes after a world
war in which in which both superpowers
try to change regimes and they did from
Japan Germany Eastern Europe to the
Philippines and then after this world
reflected the more or less the existing
power relations they began to contain
each other but there was a regime change
and actually well into the Cold War um
yes there wasn't a military intervention
but pinochet's chile changes in a year
changes all over the world the changes
by the Soviets and the Cubans I mean it
was containment with a game of change
now when we come to the present
situation Afghanistan if we reconstruct
and I'm not defending the New York
answer as maybe you know but I have been
heavily involved in the Iraq where issue
which I will not talk about now
Afghanistan was a typical defensive
strategy from an international law point
of view an attack by the united states
on the United States hosted by a
government the Taliban's the United
States paid lip service try to negotiate
with the Taliban to oust and hand de
Qaeda people study bond refused which
was a legitimate defense from the point
of view of international law and that's
why the intervention of in Afghanistan
is now led by the NATO unlike the
Coalition of the Willing in the case of
Iraq how would you characterize that
it's exactly a strategy of containment
actually that you go to the states that
have beyond any doubt protected these
people kept them on their land cell
terrorists 1998 the embassies the
American embassies in kenya and then
2001 so why is it that i am not allowed
to do that iraq as i said is a totally
different story and I do not disagree
with you on that so I partly agree with
what you say I'd be interested in what
my colleagues would say about your
observation I i disagree i think that
containment and regime change are indeed
distinguishable but it's not my view
that throughout the Cold War that
us only engaged in containment of course
the u.s. engaged in the pursuit of
regime change at many different points
abandoning containment you know since we
talked about the Middle East the most
obvious thing in Iran in 1953 active
regime change which for which we paid
paid a huge price later and we continue
to pay so it's not the case that that
but that's not to say regime change in
containment are the same thing now you
bring up the example of Afghanistan what
I would say about the Afghan situation
is the following after nine eleven
regime change in Afghanistan was not
inevitable we could we we gave the
Taliban regime the option of turning
over the turning over bin Laden and then
giving access to the cancer and so forth
they refused that and that's what
legitimated the regime change in
Afghanistan had they been willing had
they been willing to allow an
international force assuming the Afghan
regime itself was too weak to do this
but it allow an international force to
come in and pursue bin Laden and
al-qaeda after nine eleven there would
have been no reason to bump off the
Taliban regime from the perspective of
containment you know containment you
only Ratchet it up as far as you have to
do in order to achieve the goal
promoting democracy is another matter
all together and the conditions under
which you use regime change to do that I
argue a few few and far between I would
just if I could yes mr. just briefly
plead for a little more precision in
labeling I still have trouble regarding
this example as containment and perhaps
that's because I'm a historian and I see
containment as bound by certain times
and places
were analogous situations in which the
strategy of containment was ever applied
I think this was retaliation there any
number of other good words that we could
use for this but I'm still a little
puzzled as to why in you seek to crowd
so much under the tent of containment
which it seems to me muddys the meaning
of the term well we think is an
interesting comparison might be the
Cuban Missile Crisis her again there was
you know there was a choice about just
how far to push and and against the
advice of his many people around him
Kennedy it would only push as far as he
had to push in order to get the result
rather than I'm actually invade Cuba I'm
it was a good thing that he did no we
don't how about I time for these
encouraging please well I was just going
to say ladies and gentlemen that I think
it's perfectly fair for us to focus upon
professor Shapiro's use and definition
of containment and then the criticisms
which are made of it I we will be a far
wider field Ernesto for us to have a
debate right now on we're regime change
fits into this if you don't mind my
saying so if you look at the history of
state since 1945 I would guess that a
large number of the regime changes have
not been caused by American action are
not being caused by containment regime
change in South Africa rule and we end
apartheid regime change in Argentina and
Brazil when you get rid of the generals
so I would beg your questions to go
cracking on it Ian on his containment
book
regime change scenario which is to wider
field last question because the wine is
going to get rotted would be trying I I
apologize for being the last one to keep
you here thank you very much I I had a
question as to the mechanism by which
you can contain something as amorphous
as the strategic leadership of a
terrorist organization and the only
method that I find and I'm an
undergraduate so it's very possible i
didn't grapple all of everything you had
to say but but but but the thing is the
only mechanism i found was so food was
to put pressure on garments that support
these regimes but what happens when
these garments themselves a two-week
like in pakistan or like in africa where
you know the al-qaeda can very well
survive without you know even the
support of the official government well
the the argument in the book is the
problem with weak states is huge there's
a negative argument that the bush the
bush administration's approach makes
that problem worse so what is there to
do the obviously the the medium run
answer to this is to do the things that
are more likely to turn weak states into
functioning states and that's economic
development promoting economic
development principally and things like
that but of course in the short run and
in this context we not we're worried
about the security threat that comes out
of weak states so that's not very
helpful by its terms and and I and but
my the argument in the book is apart
from things like better intelligence and
human intelligence in particular and
there's some possibilities with
financial intelligence and so on that
help you know the plot to blow up
airliners last August over the North
Atlantic was basically foiled by
following financial transactions despite
the hawala system and all of that it is
possible to get quite far with that but
but there really only two mechanisms
that are available in the short run one
is regional alliances working with the
neighbors of these countries
and who both had will often have an
interest in stability and in for
instance ceiling borders because they
are subject to the downside as well as
the upside of terrorists going in and
out and so so you have to do that and
then working with international agencies
who are often in a country like Somalia
the only players who really know very
much about who the key warlords are and
what their resources are and where they
can go next you know that the UN they're
the people who are in there already
conducting relief operations may be
dealing with with AIDS and so on so
contra cannon I I argue in the book that
that working with international agencies
and working with but potential veto
players around the borders is really the
only possible thing one can do to pursue
containment of threats to democracy that
emanates from weak states thank you very
much well I think we have run out of
time unfortunately we could have spent
hours and hours so fascinating topic let
me just think professors goddess and
Kennedy for having taken some time of
their overloaded schedule to read on
short notice on short delivery Ian's
book and for participating in this
session and let me close by
congratulating Ian for having as I said
venture into the muddy waters of foreign
policy I think we need more professors
the waiting writing arguing about these
issues and that's why I will celebrate
with you now the publication of this
book
you